so I have a best friend melabochko we've
been best friends since I was seven
years old so we are celebrating 40 Years
of friendship oh my gosh wow
she's you know she's the type that will
like just take a candle or a sweater or
you know I don't have nice purses so
she's not going to grab one of my bags
but like it's funny and endearing so she
takes your if it's your candle she
smells it she likes it she just takes it
yeah that's pretty much mouth understood
so
um the other day she came to stay with
me and she loved my cats so at the end
of the trip she was like listen I really
bonded with these cats and I was just
wondering can I take them with me what
I'm not kidding I literally was like Mel
the cats are staying with me off limits
that is hilarious
um what did Frankie say again I think
she said if you touch my cat I'll kill
you oh
that's more direct yeah